le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe débute aujourd'hui une tournée
européenne sergueï lavrov sera en
hongrie notamment pour parler des
relations de la russie avec l'union
européenne et l'otan pour plus de
précision on va tout de suite retrouvé
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
cléroux
[Musique]
bonjour antoine alors sergueï lavrov
entame donc ce mardi une tournée
européenne avec la hongrie
oui tout à fait olivier le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères est reçue
ce matin à budapest et dans le cadre
d'un déplacement en europe lors duquel
il se rendra également en autriche puis
en italie la hongrie est sans doute
aujourd'hui l'un des pays d'europe avec
lequel la russie entretient les
meilleures relations c'est par exemple
actuellement le seul pays de l'union
européenne avoir approuvé l'utilisation
de spoutnik v à l'heure actuelle environ
un million de hongrois ont reçu le
vaccin russe sergueï lavrov rencontrera
donc son homologue hongrois pour
approfondir les relations bilatérales
ainsi que pour aborder les grands sujets
de l'actualité internationale comme par
exemple les relations avec l'union
européenne l'otan la situation dans le
haut-karabagh ou encore le cren un pli
qui comprend des frontières à la fois
avec la russie et la hongrie rendez vous
donc en milieu de journée pour la
conférence de presse des deux hommes
merci beaucoup en douane pour ces
précisions thuan claireaux en direct
depuis moscou